[Music]  it's citing news for Mama June fans on  the bomb diggity calm period the 37 year  old reality star is returning to TV on  Monday we TV announced that mama June  from not too hot is coming back for a  second season with 10 new episodes  airing in 2018 the show will continue to  document mama June's dramatic weight  loss journey honestly I feel pretty good  but there's some other big news to cover  too June 17 year old daughter pumpkin  made an announcement of her own Anhui  TVs website Monday morning hey guys  guess what I'm pregnant  I don't know what I'm having yet but if  I had a bet because of all the girls in  our family I'm probably having a girl  the reality star says she's really  nervous about having a baby my baby  right his head is like the size of a  freaking watermelon so imagine trying to  push a watermelon out of your vagina no  not okay as for what type of grandma she  thinks mama June will be Carolyn C but  should you go  [Music]